with the world's digital landscape
leaning more towards programming
languages and their applications there
are bound to be a plethora of
opportunities for trained personal yes
coding is one of the most crucial
requirements for practically any
profession in the developer industry
including web development machine
learning data science and others
and year after year we witness how the
ranking of various programming languages
change in response to their demand and
popularity among developers meanwhile to
remain relevant in the id sector you
must stay up to speed on all current
programming language trends and indexes
beginners in particular must carefully
evaluate various critical factors such
as popularity career growth and so on
before setting on a programming language
today we will take you through the most
in demand coding languages recommended
for college students to take up so they
are ready for the job market right after
graduation
python we begin our list with perhaps
the most trending language right now
which is python
python has been the preferred language
of practically everyone who has just
gotten started in the programming world
for many years
the fundamental reason for this is
because the syntax is relatively basic
making it easy to read understand and
apply
the language is widely used for software
engineering web development and other
related tasks and various emerging
technologies such as learning algorithms
artificial intelligence predictive
analysis and so on
as per the red monk ranking survey for
2020 python has surpassed java as the
second most popular programming language
in the previous five years the language
has grown at a rate of roughly 18 to 19
percent python is ranked first in the
pypl index for december 2020. the
language is also among the most popular
programming languages on several
well-known sites including stack
overflow github and others
furthermore python's interoperability
with rising technologies such as ai and
ml makes it more appealing to developers
python is used to develop 2d imaging and
3d animation
software such as blender inkscape and
autodesk
it has also been employed to develop
popular video games such as civilization
4 vegas strike and tone town
python is utilized by famous websites
such as youtube and instagram and
scientific and computational
applications such as free cad and abacus
python engineers make about 75 000 us
dollars or 4.2 lakhs per year on average
next up we have a relatively new
language called kotlin kotlin is a
statically typed general purpose
programming language that may be used
for both object oriented and functional
programming
the language's most remarkable features
is that it is fully compatible with java
and supports all the java libraries
furthermore the language is relatively
simple to learn and it can be used for
web programming and software development
for desktop platforms along with android
it was released in 2016.
following google's announcement of
kotlin as their preferred language for
android application development there
has been a significant shift in
developer preference
according to the stack overflow study
kotlin is the fourth most popular
programming language
in addition the github community's
number of kotlin users is rapidly
growing
java javelin ktor and vertx are among
the prominent frameworks for kotlin an
organization such as pinterest uber
netflix and others are hiring kotlin
engineers
because it is well known that the
android market is not going away anytime
soon you might choose to study kotlin in
2022 for some great employment chances
in the future
kotlin developers can earn as much as 5
lakhs rupees as average base salary or
136 000 us dollars per year
moving on we have java
our third spot the object-oriented
programming language introduces the
well-known notion of write once run
anywhere which allows java code to be
run on another system that supports java
without requiring a recompilation
the language is frequently utilized in
android development and web applications
desktop software and scientific
applications so on
furthermore top-tier organizations such
as adobe amazon flipkart and others use
java and provide enticing employment
prospects to java engineers
its significant demand in the tech world
extensive community support popular
framework such as spring and hibernate
and several enriching features such as
multi-threading automatic memory
allocation and garbage collection
platform independence and so on ensure
that java will provide you with a lot of
valuable career opportunities in the
coming years as well
as a java developer college students
stand a chance to earn an average of 95
000
or 4.5 lakh inr per year
c c
plus
even after years and years of
development c and c plus plus remain a
staple in the it industry and they take
the fourth spot on our list today
c is the most basic and widely used
computer language and it provides the
foundation for other coding languages
like c java and javascript c plus is a
more advanced variant of c
c and c plus plus programmers may
utilize compilers for a broad range of
platforms making programs written in
these languages very portable
c and c plus are both considered high
performance programming languages
ado microsoft oracle
nvidia and other large tech businesses
regularly employ c c plus plus
professionals with competitive paid
packages
and learning cc plus in 2022 would be
advantageous from a professional
standpoint and make it simpler to learn
other computer languages later on
season c plus plus developers can expect
an average salary of 8 lakhs rupees or
73 000 per year
go the final slot in our most
recommended programming languages list
belongs to the language go
google created go in 2007 for apis and
online apps because of its flexibility
and its capacity to control multi-crore
and interconnected systems and massive
code bases go has lately become one of
the most popular programming languages
google created
go a statically typed computer language
with a syntax comparable to c
it has various useful functions like
garbage collection type safety dynamic
typing excellent performance efficiency
etc
there has been a relatively sudden
uptick in the last few years in goes
popularity with stack overflows
reporting go as one of the most loved
programming languages in the world
companies such as uber google and others
are using the go language and you can
opt to study it since the language
appears to be growing in the popularity
in the future years
a developer with mastery of the go
programming language can expect to earn
an average salary of 130 000 us dollars
or 8.2 lakhs rupees per year
we hope this video has cast some light
on the current and future demands of the
coding industry and which direction
college students can focus on to buy the
best offer post graduation
feel free to ask us your queries in the
comment section below and we will answer
them for you as soon as possible
subscribe to simply learn channel for
more videos like this and thank you for
watching
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here